whenever I use a gaming headset like
Astros or SteelSeries or whatever I come
away feeling like I'm listening to
something made by play slowly it's just
garbage it's just like a kid's toy yeah
I totally know what you mean Andy I've
got some pretty sick headphones that I
have for like my head listening to music
and stuff jammin out yeah but then I go
to play my ps4 and I'm stuck eating like
this really expensive crap I mean I've
already got the nice headphones so I
just need to I need to figure out how to
use those with my ps4 or my xbox
that's my issue and you want to have
in-game chat work pretty easily so first
we thought maybe we could use like a
headphone amp or a mix amp or something
but it turns out that's a real pain in
the ass because then it's not Wireless
anymore and we also didn't notice much
audio improvement like we tried to a/b
test it and it just didn't seem like we
could recommend dropping 100 bucks or
something on solutions like that so all
we had to do was figure out how to marry
a microphone to a really nice headphones
and then get that into the ps4
controller so we managed to do it pretty
cheaply all we needed to do is get a
pretty affordable lab and a Y cable that
combines our headphones with our mic you
can plug that right into your controller
and with the Xbox one you can get the
adapter and that lets you mute it and
everything and also we tested different
mics and when you're on party chat it's
pretty low quality anyways so don't
spend too much on a money yeah I mean
our solution it was pretty janky but it
worked really well on ps4 PC and the
Xbox one it was ten dollars for the
microphone I used and seven for that
adapter and that's all you need to do to
rock in-game chat and you're not
sacrificing any audio experience because
you're using your for me I'm using my
bare dynamics which are just yeah if you
already got them this only cost you 17
bucks to get it going now one thing is
if you're not interested in dropping you
know 200 plus dollars on a high fiber
headphones like we have already have
what is a good gaming headset because
like we were saying we think all of them
are kinda bad that we've used we
obviously haven't used them all but we
did try out one that was pretty sick
the Kingston HyperX cloud a $70 kick-ass
gaming it yeah it sounded great it's not
a pretty good you know I can recommend
that that a recommends that yeah it's
hot a tips that's a hot tip alright
that's about all we've got so let's stop
doing this video now okay cool and it
cut butt